what is going on everybody welcome to
part 5 of our Python with PI QT tutorial
video series in this video we're going
to be talking about is adding a main
menu to our application so main menu is
basically this where you've got like
file edit format all that stuff how do
we add that to our application so my
first question to you would be where
should we actually code a main menu so
no matter where you are on most
applications the main menu stays the
same so I think that's a good idea and
we can do that by putting the main menu
in our init method rather than putting
it in the home now as I've already shown
you you can change things dynamically in
your application with methods so if
you're like well what if I ever want to
change the main menu based on the screen
or the view well you can do that it
would just be silly though to put a main
menu in each kind of method then when
you changed it you'd have to change it
in each method or maybe you'd have a
method that creates the main menu but
you'd still have to call it in every
single view it would be stupid so we're
going to code that in the init method so
before we get to home and after we do
this Python logo we're going to code the
stuff for our main menu so let's just
come on down to here and get started so
first of all what do we want the main
menu to do so the easiest thing I can
think of is you've got a file and you've
got an exit ok so that's what we're
going to code so you've got we're going
to call this extract action so we're
going to get ourselves out of this
application extract action is going to
equal Qt GUI cue action so cue action
what's that from oh it's from QT why do
we know it's got the cue cue action and
the action we're gonna want to do we use
this ampersand and then we're gonna say
get to the choppa mm-hmm picture babies
when you do you think of that and then
self so that's what our action is going
to be now we can do something like this
between say extract
chin because now that's a cue action
object so now what we can do is we can
assign a shortcut to that cue action
object so you can say extract action set
shortcut and here you just specify the
shortcut so ours is going to be ctrl + Q
that's usually what quit is so we'll use
the same kind of standards and then can
you imagine if you just like made it I
don't know s
I'm not sure you can even do that we'll
have to try that that would be funny
anyway it really makes people angry
extract action dot set status tip and
we'll just have to say leave the app now
what is this the status bar is this
thing right here at the bottom so it's
the thing that has like the line count
and stuff and luckily for us the status
tip is so simple that we don't really
need to code much for it all we have to
do when we kind of call the status tip
is we need to just say self dot status
bar that's it so that just calls the
status bar into being and we've already
set the status tip so we that's
literally all we have to do when it
comes to a status bar
super simple now what do we want to do
finally with extract action is we want
to do extract action triggered so
anytime this is triggered so it's kind
of like our clicked down here but then
we're going to have the same dot connect
so we'll do dot connect what do we want
it to do well this is leaving the
application so we use the same method
that we created before self dot close
application again I promise we'll have
some new fancy methods before you know
it do that
we'll keep the stash bar that's fine and
then now that we've done that so we've
created like the menu kind of choice but
now we have to create the actual main
menu so then what we do is we're going
to say main menu equals self dot menu
bar boom we've done it just kind of like
self dot status bar now let me ask you
this why did we have to assign self dot
menu bar to a main menu
variable when we didn't have to do it
for statusbar well the difference is
this even if we just simply called self
dot menu bar we would have a menu bar
object it would be there and we would
have created it no different than we've
already done in here but what we need to
do is we need to modify minibar burger
and add things to it we're going to add
file we're going to add this extract
action to it and all of that so because
we want to modify it we need to assign
it to a variable so sometimes that can
be confusing like when do I need to
assign something to a variable well
that's when when you want to actually
modify it so we're in assigned to main
menu and then we're going to say a file
menu and file menu is going to be main
menu dot add menu and that menu that
we're going to add is we're going to
ampersand whoops in quotes universe and
Wow so that's the name of the menu then
whoops then what we're going to do is
file menu dot add action and then we
want to add extract action and that's it
that's really all you have to do now it
seems like a lot but now we want anytime
we want to add something to the file
menu you would basically make these four
lines again you don't need to touch this
one ever again once you've defined it
once make these four lines for whatever
you want and then to add it to the menu
the file menu at least with file here
all you would do is file menu to add
action whatever the next action was that
you created so we'll add more as time
goes on but that's how you would do it
so now we'll save and run it and our
quit button is in the way
let's close that and let's fix that
really quick let's put this back at a
let's do a 100 100 and in fact we'll
leave it at zero for the X but 100 for
the Y okay so now we can actually have a
file and so there's your file we can
click it get to the choppa and it exits
and we can also let's check the the
shortcut ctrl Q exits now just for my
viewing for your viewing pleasure let's
just leave Q let's just see if that'll
work
hahaha that could be a lot of fun um
that's pretty brutal you just make it
like a make it some vowel or something
make it a chat program anyway yeah you
I'm gonna turn you guys into really
popular rap creators at the end of this
so anyway that's it with part 5 and
creating the main menu like I said we'll
add some more stuff to it will make more
menus I encourage you to go ahead and
try try to add something else to the
file menu even if it's just another
version of quitting try to add something
else and then even try to add a new main
menu menu right so add another menu like
edit or something like that we're going
to do that in this series but let's see
if you you understand it enough to go
ahead and edit it or kind of play around
it doesn't take too long to just trial
and error until you have it so anyways
that's it with this video if you have
any questions or comments up to this
point please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time